mai 1948 une jeune princesse de 22 ans
vient pour la première fois en france
elizabeth d'angleterre a choisi la part
des bars c'est aussi son tout premier
voyage officiel en tant que princesse
d'angleterre à paris c'est un événement
les forces de l'ordre ont bien du mal à
contrôler la foule
première étape pour elisabeth l'elysée
elle est reçue par le président vincent
auriol le président de la république l'a
salué au nom de la france et l'a remis
le grand perdant de la légion d'honneur
en même temps qu'il décorait de la croix
de guerre le duc d'edimbourg à l'époque
elizabeth est surnommé par la presse
française la petite princesse
d'angleterre prochaine destination
l'avenue des champs elysées la voici qui
l'a remonte jusqu'à l'arc de triomphe ou
à payer par le général giraud elle
s'inclinait devant la pierre qui garde
le plus obscur et le plus glorieux des
soldats ensuite en route pour le palais
galliera au programme pour la princesse
une exposition puis un discours sur
l'amitié franco-anglaise et en français
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
défendue au prix de notre part il fait
le client met en commun les dons et les
vertus qui par leur héritage le plus
fier
la pop et la grande bretagne doivent
prendre la direction du mouvement
maintenant direction un autre lieu
mythique le château de versailles et là
aussi les français sont venus accueillir
chaleureusement la princesse
pour les journalistes prendre une photo
d'elisabeth relève du parcours du
combattant et la police sans
bienveillance exécutrice par trop rigide
d'ordre mal fondées n'a permis de
montrer de la princesse à versailles que
ces quelques scènes rapides presque
arraché par surprise
l'opération séduction se poursuit sur la
scène avec une petite balade
embarquement immédiat à bord d'un bateau
son nom princess elisabeth la traversée
par sabre est grave et la selle d'un
pari plus de deux fois millénaire et qui
après avoir souvent remis au nom des
anglais a juste maintenant le plus gros
si elle du monde au plus noble des
paysages pour mieux recevoir une
princesse britannique
[Musique]
quatre ans plus tard en 1952 la
princesse elisabeth devient reine du
royaume uni en 2022 elle fête son jubilé
de platine soit 70 ans de règne record
historique pour un monarque britannique
[Musique]